Internet phenom Matthew Newland causes  chaos by dropping red hot nickel balls  to anything he can get his hands on  crayons to honey so far have an  incredible million but our experts just  love seeing a red hot nickel ball in  cold what's with all the strange sci-fi  sounds what's happened here is that the  nickel ball is so hot is created a layer  of water vapor the layer of gas forms  little bubbles and because gas is  lighter than water it rises to the  surface as these bubbles rise they cool  and so the bubble begins to shrink as  each bubble closes in it emits the air  in a very rapid form and these  vibrations propagate through the water  to the surface and they hit the air that  sets the air vibrating and that's what  exactly what we perceive a sound  eventually the nickel ball cools down so  much that the steam layer collapses  causing a cascade of tiny bubbles which  we hear as a wish